Stavo con questo ragazzo molto carino, molto dolce che quando arrivava il momento di aprire l'idrante
manco fosse Bruce Banner che si trasforma in Hulk, cominciava a fare "UAAAAAAAA"
La prima volta sono rimasta scioccata, poi mi sono abituata
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata, il tema della
puntata di oggi è "Ex"...Mi è uscito "BAHH". "EX"
Per un tema così importante ho pensato di invitare all'interno degli studios di casa mia
l'unica persona che ha diciamo un
passato più burrascoso del mio e molto
più infelice rispetto al mio, una persona
che conosco bene che è la mia cuginetta
preferita. Purtroppo lei non poteva
venire e quindi ho optato per Lavinia. Ciao a tutti. Ciao Lavi. Grazie per questa pubblicità meravigliosa
che mi hai fatto anche se però amo
definirmi più una guru delle relazioni
fallimentari in realtà, nonché infelice. Infelice tanto. Lavinia è mia cugina. No in realtà io so una che
passava qua sotto e poi mi hai detto "Senti ma ti va di fare mia cugina?"
Ho pensato che fosse
la persona migliore per trattare un tema
così spinoso, io ho il terrore di quello
che potrebbe uscire fuori...così scottante si
Io sono qui per prendere i vostri consigli
fondamentalmente, si, si
Il mio ex ragazzo faceva l'aeroplanino con il suo gingillo davanti a sua mamma. Ma in che senso?!
Ma non ci possono avvertì prima quando mi dicono ste cose?
L'elicottero poi perché non è un aeroplano ma è un elicottero. Ha detto aeroplano?
E sua madre me la immagino tipo
Beyoncé con l'aria davanti durante il concerto capito?
Tipo così...capito avanti.. Ciao Gu ciao ospite, oggi volevo raccontarti di quella volta in cui
ho conosciuto questo ragazzo, siamo usciti
una sera e a fine serata mi fa "Io devo
chiederti una cosa". Sembra molto
preoccupato che tranquillizzandolo
"Dimmi pure, c'è qualcosa che non va?".
"Devo dirti che mi piacciono i calci nelle p***e"
puoi tirarmene uno prima di andare a casa?"
Noooo! Non l'ho mai più rivisto
Ciao Gu. Ciao cara. "Posso darti del tu? No ti prego dammi un calcio sui maroni
Lungi da me voler giudicare le attitudini e le opzioni
sessuali di ciascuno di noi però diciamo
che proprio appena conosciuta forse era
un po' "too much". Una persona che avevo
conosciuto che voleva preaticamente...Oddio! Oddio non lo so se sono pronta
Il mio ex arrotolava i peli del pube, li staccava, faceva la pallina e li appoggiava sulla
sponda del letto, pure sul comodino e io quando pulivo trovavo tutti queste palline di pelo in giro ma
Ma gli dava pure un nome? Cioè nel senso poi diventavano
"Notte Jeremy, notte Thomas...parte della famiglia. Hey hey hey. Che fine ha fatto Miky, hai spazzato via Miky?
La cosa bella è se avesse fatto tipo un
maglione, una sciarpa capito? Lady Gaga ai tempi d'oro se la sarebbe messa subito
Ciao Gu ciao ospite, io sono stata un anno con un individuo particolare. Giusto per farvi un esempio
della sua follia, una volta per sostenere
il fatto che non gli facesse schifo la sua m***a
si è c****o in mano e mi ha mostrato
la sua m***a. Che prova di forza!
Voglio capire pure a monte l'alterco. "Tu non sai
chi sono io!
Io mi c**o in mano!". Come si è arrivati a questo? "Ah tu pensi che io non ci riesco? Garda che faccio. BAM!"
Chissà cosa ha portato la m***a a finire su quella mano!
Ciao Willwoosh ciao ospite, il mio ex ha uno strano rapporto con la cacca. Lui per paura di
otturare...la lancia via dal balcone...glie la metteva in mano a quell'altro...faceva la cacca in un sacchetto
In un sacchetto? Aspetta aspetta
Io lei la amo. Faceva la cacca in un sacchetto, poi siccome gli faceva schifo pulirsi, viveva con
sua madre e si faceva pulire il sedere da sua madre. E la cosa ancora più bella è disse sorridendo
"Dai amore un giorno toccherà anche a te". Nonono questo è un minuto di silenzio
per tutti quanti quei sacchetti. Ma quale madre degenere il
Benvenuti nel mondo dei "mannini". Ma la madre!
A te bisogna toglie l'affidamento di tuo figlio
se a 25 anni gli pulisci ancora il c**o letteralmente...e non in senso metaforico
Care mie mi state consolando in una maniera inenarrabile perché pensavo di averli beccati tutti io
e invece. Per il momento sono tutte
ragazze. E facciamocela una domanda e diamocela
una risposta eh? Praticamente durante un rapporto sessuale lui mi chiamo "vacca". Inizialmente mi ero
offesa però ho continuato tranquillamente,
poi il giorno dopo ne parlammo, lui mi
disse che non era un'offesa ma lui
intendeva vacca nel senso delle mie tette
"Bella topolona mia!". Alché qualche tempo
dopo sempre durante un rapporto sessuale
io gli dissi "Sei un porco" e lui si alzò, mi
lasciò a letto e io rimasi basita. Alché
lo seguii e lo trovai chiuso in bagno,
seduto, a piangere come un bambino perché si offese
perché io lo chiamai "porco"...Diciamo che..."Oh si bel porco"
"Ci sarai!"...Partiamo dal presupposto che questa qui è
roba da pivelli. Il termine vacca a volte
anche viene utilizzato...quale è un modo
carino per dire peripatetica?
Peripatetica si può usare, potremmo usare anche t***a, b***h, z*****a
Cioè sono quelle cose "Un pochino ti insulto
perché in realtà ti piace"...Per fare
colore durante l'atto no? Ma anche porco. "Ah che porco!". Capito è quella roba un
pochino sì. Certo si, si si. E invece loro due invece di eccitarsi si ferivano a vicenda
E' tutta roba di colore, non ti devi sentire in colpa
né devi pensare che sia stato un giudizio
Mi fa ridere lui. Assolutamente no, assolutamente no. Chiuso dentro al bagno. "Dove ho sbagliato?"
Ti volevo raccontare di un mio ex, un giorno entro in camera sua
lui mi dice "Svestiti" e poi mi fa indossare i suoi vestiti
Alché mi guarda e mi dice "Ho sempre
sognato di s*****e me stesso!"
Ah approfitto anche per dirti che ti seguo
da quando ho 13 anni, bacio
E adesso ne ho 14 (Enrico)...Hai presente quello di Scary Movie? "E così sembro gay?"
Che le mette il suo coso da rugbista "Vai
Jack vai". Camuffami la voce e sappi che amo
te e i tuoi video da quando ero un
undicenne. Grazie per avermi...e ora ne ho 12
Ciao Gu, ti voglio raccontare di un ragazzo con cui mi sono frequentata un paio di volte e del motivo per cui
è degno di nota. Subito dopo che raggiungeva l'apice
massimo del piacere scoppiava a ridere. Vabbè...carino, leggero, goliardico, se la fa piglià a bene. Bravo!
Menomale che esiste ancora gente che ride. Pensa che quello di prima sta ancora in bagno a piagne
Quello prima ancora si sta ancora defecando nelle mani. Mettiamoli
tutti dentro in una stanza. Regà c'è un problema con internet. Internet sono quelle "così"?
Si, si chiama wi fi. Enrico ma tu, ma è il 2019! Veramente ancora non sa qual'è il coso del Wi fi! (Gianmarco)
La differenza fra essere collegato al wi fi e il fatto che il wy wuay...il wa fa...Quelle specie di cose
Ciao Gu ciao ospite, volevo raccontarti di
una richiesta strana fatta dal mio ex a letto
dove mi chiedeva di leccargli il naso
in particolar modo nelle narici, perché lo eccitava tantissimo. Non sapevo nemmeno fossero erogene
Vuoi provare? Il suo concetto di masturbazione
era questo...Io non ci riesco.No io nemmeno di dare
Lasciati dare una mano...E' piacevolissimo!  Fui invitato a questo matrimonio, primo matrimonio da single
dopo anni di coppia. Una delle damigelle mostrò interesse per me, mi
portò in giardino per consumare. Mentre
io ero dietro la ragazza ha incominciato
a urlarmi "Dimmi di nitrire, dimmi di nitrire, dimmi di nitrire! Sono la tua centaura, la tua bellissima
centaura. Dimmi di nitrire. Come se non bastasse ha incominciato a tirare
testate contro il muro di ciottoli finché non si è tagliata la fronte
Dimmi che non è vero! Non sapevo come giustificarlo
agli altri ospiti quando c'hanno rivisto, pensavano che gli avessi
alzato mani, cosa che non è così. Tu immaginati, aspetta
No non ce la faccio. "Dimmi che sono la tua centaura". "BOOM!"
"O ma che fine hanno fatto x e y? Boh non lo so". "IHHIH  BUM, IHIH BUM". Io conosco una ragazza che
si è fatta a spaccare il naso contro un
termosifone, come i pugili. Per la gioia di
tutti i chirurghi estetici d'Italia. Si, e per i termosifoni
Cosa? Comunque è una leggenda quella dei pugili che...(Enrico)
E' una leggenda? Chi è che c'ha le orecchie gonfie? I lottatori di judo dove ci sta sfregamento (Enrico)
Tu hai visto le orecchie dei lottatori di judo? Non lo
so ero troppo presa a pensare a pugili
lottatori, niente mi ero già innamorata ed è tutto finito
Mandateci i vostri curriculum vitae qui sotto...Posso fare un appello? Vai vai. No io bado molto alle skills
intellettuali quindi se siete
rugbisti oppure...mandate il vostro
curriculum. Mi sta piazzando Siri...Oddio taglia questa cazzata ti prego!
Non la taglierò (Enrico). Se siete rugbisti mandate il curriculum
Il mio ex a vent'anni si faceva allacciare le
scarpe dalla nonna e dalla zia. Che
cucciolo! Ma allora sti cuccioli di Gnu non
sono capitati solo a me! Eh tu sei avvelenata coi...Siiiii!Siii!.Tu li odi? Si
Ritengo però che ci siano buone
opportunità che i rugbisti non siano così
Sta impazzendo, sta perdendo il senno lei, c'è un inquinamento
acustico così elevato. Io sto diventando sordo da qui a furia di sentirmi urlare in questo
orecchio. "RUGBISTI, AAAAAAA". Non parlo più
non dirò di più quella parola, leggete il labiale. Voglio raccontare di quella volta in cui io ero con il mio
primo ragazzo, entrambi alle prime armi.
A un certo punto quando lui doveva scendere verso
di me, si blocca, mi guarda e fa"E' bagnata!"
E io lo guardo e dico "Si, e?"
Fa "No a me piace asciutta". A secco proprio, con la cazzuola "Che me lo svuoti un bilico?".
E' come se lei avesse detto "A me piace morbido"
perché mi piace fare "questo" tutto il tempo. Ma lui non aveva mai...
E beh penso proprio di no, infatti lei ci
dice che era già alle primissime armi, le frecce
Credo che lui abbia fatto tipo lui è sceso
"Oddio l'ombelico", è sceso "Oddio un altro ombelico"
Ciao Gu ciao ospite, io sono stata sei anni con una persona, ci siamo lasciati l'anno scorso, con cui
per sei anni non ho avuto rapporti. Aveva paura che io restassi incinta. Fine della storia, ciao. Fine del dramma
come fine della storia, non possiamo
concludere con fine della storia
Questo è un dramma, nel 2019? Mai sentito parlare di
contraccettivi lui? Questi sconosciuti
Ma facevano altro? Beh ipotizzo di sì. Tipo
guardavano il tramonto, mano nella mano
A me il tenore del messaggio sembrava abbastanza chiaro. Trovati qualcuno e passa sei anni a letto
Ho ricevuto una richiesta stranissima dal
mio primissimo ex, dal nulla mi chiese di
rinchiuderlo dentro il divano letto. Cioè io dovevo guardare un film
seduto sopra il divano letto con le mie due
amiche mentre lui stava sotto perché
...lo eccitava da morire. Intero o sporzionato lo doveva mettere?
No non ha foto insieme. Il divano (Gianmarco)...Lui che chiama le amiche che vengono a casa
"Sediamoci sul divano". E nel frattempo c'è lui "così" sotto. No ma più che altro appena ti siedi "AAAA"
La mia esperienza con gli ex è un'esperienza con una ex con la quale sono stata un sacco di anni
che aveva una malattia per il pulito pazzesca
Bisognava ogni giorno aspirare casa,
togliere le coperte dal letto e aspirare
totalmente il letto e le coperte. Non
usavano le scarpe, lasciavamo fuori sullo
zerbino a costo di farcele fregare e poi
soffriva di scatti di rabbia pazzeschi per
cui aveva l'abitudine quando le capitava
sotto mano del cibo durante una lite di
farlo tipo detonare. Poi però impazziva e
cominciava ad aspirare tutto e da lì in
poi sono andata a vivere da sola e
adesso sono nello zozzume felicissima
Brava buona idea, brava! Sai chi non farebbe mai
una cosa così? I rugbisti. L'avrei detto io se non fossi
stata censurata fin ad'ora.
Luigi fa una cosa che io posso impazzire
Non mi parlare male di Luigi che mi arrabbio sai? Se mi stai guardando Luigi, tanto
gliel'ho detto ventimila volte e non è
l'unica persona che lo fa. Perché quando
pulite, che ne so' i piatti e cose così,
lasciate la pezzetta bagnata dentro il
lavandino. Ah no questa cosa non la faccio
nemmeno io. Senza contare che io ho uno scolino per le
pezzette che tu puoi mettere lì a
scolare. Questo non ti rende per niente una persona
particolare, vuoi andarti a mettere dentro il divano e noi ci mettiamo lì comodamente a guardare una bella
stagione di Netflix?..."Ho uno scolino apposito"
Nono mi uccide questa cosa. Tutto bene? Beh io adesso avrei da fare...
A te non è mai capitato che ad esempio di punto in
bianco stai camminando per la strada e
senti lo stesso odore del tuo ex?
Ed è lì che dici "Oddio quanti ricordi,
quante emozioni". Ma è padre Pio il tuo ex?
Per quanto ti dimentichi anche delle volte il
loro nome, appena senti l'olore ti
ricordi subito tutto. Cara ho una
soluzione. Un mio ex aveva un profumo che
mi faceva impazzire, la soluzione è che
il primo cadeau che faccio gli uomini, ai rugbisti per meglio dire, con cui esco è esattamente
quel profumo. Davvero? Un esercito di
replicanti. Io in realtà sono la morte nera capito?
Come si chiamano i cazzelli bianchi di Star Wars? Gli Stormtrooper
Esatto, tutti uguali tutti "Ma che profumo hai!". Ok
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questa puntata, io ringrazio Lavinia
Grazie a voi. Senti ti voglio dare un
piccolo cadeau, che è il mio orecchio
sinistro...Se vuoi te lo incarto dopo, te lo lascio. Guarda che sono arrivati i delfini qui davanti
Se lo state guardando con le cuffie questo video togliete la sinistra
Guardatelo coi sottotitoli che tra
parentesi, almeno dico questa cosa che
non ho mai tempo di dire, spesso mi
chiedete di rimettere i sottotitoli
sappiate che da un bel po' di mesi i
sottotitoli ci sono sotto questi video
solamente che potete attivarli. Vi do' la
possibilità o di vederlo senza
sottotitoli o se invece volete attivarli
mettere italiano e a quel punto andare con Dio
"VAI CON DIO SPIDER MAN"
Che dire ti ringrazio Lavi. Grazie
è stato veramente un piacere per me
trascorrere il mio tempo in tua
compagnia, come finta tua cugina preferita
Ora puoi tornare...Adesso torno alla mia miserrima esistenza. Saluta tua zia. Ciao mamma ciao mamma.
Ciao zia. Salutiamo L'associazione rugbisti Italia a questo punto
Vi lasciamo qua sotto i contatti di Lavinia. Come
sempre ragazzi io vi ringrazio per aver
visto questo video.
Lasciatemi un commento qua sotto se volete
commentare le storie che avete sentito o
ancora meglio se volete condividere le
vostre. Iscrivetevi a questo canale,
attivate la campanellina per non perdervi
nessun video e noi come sempre ci vediamo la prossima settimana sempre alle 14. Ciao...Ciao
Possiamo mandare un messaggio notturno tipo Inception? Rugbisti. Tipo FUMATE